في المياه المحيطة بسري لانكا ،
ستجد الصيادين الوحيدين في العالم الذين
يجلسون فوق ركيزة مصنوعة يدويًا مدفوعين
في الرمال ،
هؤلاء الصيادون هم بعض من آخر الصيادين من
نوعها ، ولكن بالنسبة لأولئك الذين ما زالوا يصطادون ،
فإن الأمر يتعلق بممارسة تقليد
موجود فقط في  هذا الجزء من العالم محمد
علي صديق ليمون ما ما الله قرأته
في وقت من تاريخ
الصيد على ركائز يقال إنه يعود إلى الحرب العالمية
الثانية عندما تسبب نقص الغذاء ونقص
القوارب المناسبة في جعل الصيادين
يبدعون من أجلهم  اصطاد الصيد من
عصا في الخارج ، ساعدهم في صيد المزيد من الأسماك
التي قام بها مولانا من قبل الرجل الذي كنت في
بطن الشخص الموجود في خيمة ، رحب البنا
بنسخة لها حقًا ، أعني
تطوير دليل تحديث NOAA الخاص بنا على محرر البدلة
التي تعرفها عن هذا  ماذا عن
صوفيا إيجل عيون
اقتصاد مارلين على وسادة الله بابا
[موسيقى]
الصيد ليس مربحًا كما كان في
السابق ،
لذا فإن معظم الصيادين على ركبتيهم لديهم وظائف
أخرى لدفع الفواتير لكنهم يستمرون في تقوية
الأسماك للحفاظ على التقليد على قيد الحياة
سلبي أو كهرماني على ما لا لاغونا مع
أكسجين بوتاسيوم بعد
مصل تسلسلي وحشي صفير مستساغ لديك
عضو في الحفلة وعاد محمد علي بهاي
اسم دش كابيلا سبها
غير معروف بالفعل إنه ليس أنا إذا لم أكن لست
مضطرًا لذلك  حتى تعال قد يكون لدي بعض
وصف آدم كالاهان
ولكنك
[موسيقى]